Jennie Garth ties but not the nine oh  two one oh Starwood actor David Abrams  Saturday at Oak Crest farms for six acre  ranch in Los Olivos California in these  pics obtained exclusively by et we see  the 43 year old looking stunning in a  floral embroidered gown with a sheer  long-sleeve overlay Jennie walked down  the aisle alone but she was joined at  the altar by her bridesmaids daughter's  luca bella lola rae and fiona e we're  told she cried the entire ceremony  especially while exchanging vows with  her new hubby and then the party began  guests including 90210 co-star Tori  Spelling looked on as Jenny and David  danced to Elton John's your song and  speaking of nine oh two one oh I and  ziering was at comic-con this weekend  but he gave et his best wishes for Jenna  jenny is is such a special person she's  so fantastic I was hoping that you'd be  able to find love again and knowing her  I'm not surprised that it's happening I  wish you the best